[Musica]
[Applauso]
camminavo per la strada sotto un cielo a
nietzsche che faceva la felicità di
alcolisti e vidal tonici e il santo
ammainava lentamente la bandiera prima
di sciogliere gli ormeggi
dall'imbarcadero aveva occhi
insanguinati e stima tlc e camminava
sulle acque tra scherno e meraviglia e
un cappotto di cammello e un chiodo
arrugginito indicavano il tempo di
quando era partito e attraversavo l'aria
e la nebbia che saliva
degli angeli custodi dall'altra parte
della riva giocavano a 37 giocavano col
morto mentre una nuova madre gridava in
sala parto
benedetta sia la gentilezza benedetto lo
stupore benedetta stia la verità se la
verità e dolore benedetto sia l'incanto
benedetta l'espiazione benedetta alla
complicità che unisce le persone
e il tempo mi scappava ma in fondo ero
contento la vista un po più debole e in
cielo un firmamento di luci di natale di
polveri viola di voci di bambini
all'uscita della scuola
e mentre i bambini crescono crescono
così tanto cercavo comprensione tra le
stigmate del santo ma il santo è pura
luce e pur anestesia è più la resistenza
è pura cortesia e allora giù d'un fiato
un litro di vetriolo che per quanto se
ne dica sa fare il suo lavoro corrode in
tempo zero chili di cellulosa la fede
daro bianca e il suo abito da sposa
benedetta se la gentilezza benedetto lo
stupore benedetta sia la verità e la
verità e dolore
benedetto sia l'incanto benedetta
l'espiazione benedetta la complicità che
unisce le persone
[Musica]
e ballavamo sotto il portico di luce
messicana e la federa cenere e nutriva
all'erba grana
mentre alimentava i segni della fine
senza aver delimitato la mia linea di
confine
pensavo solo in rima e le rime si
baciavano
pensavo che invecchiamo i miei giorni si
accorciavano il battito cardiaco
rallentava dolcemente e il santos
compariva confuso tra la gente
pensavo solo in riva e le rime
litigavano
pensavo che invecchiamo i miei sogni si
accorciavano pensavo al mio futuro e non
vedevo quasi niente e il santos
compariva sotto il sole di ponente
benedetta sì alla luce che ci illumina
il cammino benedetta la bottiglia che
trasforma l'acqua in vino
benedetta la dolcezza che diventa
commozione benedetto sia il pensiero
benedetto come il pane benedetta la
gentilezza benedetto lo stupore
benedetta sia la verità se la verità e
dolore benedetto sia l'incanto benedetta
l'espiazione benedetta la complicità che
unisce le persone
[Musica]
grazie
io mi chiamo federico sirianni sono nato
a genova e di mestiere faccio il
cantautore che so in una se non sia in
una condizione di riconoscibilità
particolarmente mainstream sostenere la
tesi di riuscire a vivere facendo musica
in italia è qualcosa di poco credibile
però a volte accade il mio intervento
parla di storia e anche di luoghi di
come certi luoghi siano raccontabili
attraverso delle storie in qualunque
forma dalla narrazione alla canzone e di
come certe storie non possano fare a
meno di un luogo per esprimersi in
maniera completa ma anche di come la
forza di una storia e della sua
narrazione possa intervenire nelle
dinamiche dei meccanismi nelle
traiettorie di un'esistenza come vedete
ho una chitarra con me è il mio
strumento del mestiere insieme alla
penna che in realtà uso pochissimo
invece uso molti tasti freddi di un
computer antico ma efficiente
l'esperienza ad esempio che che posso
portare qualcosa di di molto volatile in
realtà è qualcosa che bisogna saper
guardare e afferrare con la leggerezza
con cui si può prendere in mano una
farfalla senza ferirla e senza farle
male
l'esperienza che posso portare non verrà
mai prese in considerazione per una
startup un qualcosa del genere perché si
basa su qualcosa che si muove liquida
nell'aria che gira intorno a noi che
tutti possiamo cogliere ma che
pochissimi utilizzato e sto parlando
appunto delle storie avete presente
quante decine quante centinaia quante
migliaia di storie stiamo affollando
adesso questo spazio stiano tamponandosi
nell'aria e quante magari senza averci
prestato attenzione avete ascoltato da
quando siete qui non dico nelle sale
conferenze insomma qui ci si viene
apposta in noi intendo dire quando siete
in metropolitana sugli autobus in
ascensore al bar camminando per strada
beh se avesse ascoltato tutte queste
storie
probabilmente ne avreste ascoltate molte
particolarmente banali di poco interesse
al 3 con qualche particolare in grado di
sollecitare la vostra attenzione
ma ci sarebbe stata sicuramente qualche
storia memorabile di quelle che restano
stampate nella memoria e nel cuore che
ti si marchiano col fuoco sulla pelle e
perché no possono anche cambiarti
l'esistenza e il mio mestiere è
soprattutto quello di individuare le
storie e con quelle lavorarci
io sono un ladro di storie uno stalker
di storie mi capita di abusare
l'orecchio ai discorsi dei vicini di
tavolo o di seguire furtivamente ignare
coppie per capire che cosa si dicono non
c'è teatro migliore dell'umanità e come
ben si sa la realtà batte in volata la
fantasia
se io vi raccontassi solo alcuni dei
fatti che mi sono capitati facendo
questo mestiere la maggior parte di voi
mi considererebbe un millantatore non mi
crederebbe e invece ogni cosa che ogni
cosa che racconto è vera in una vita
precedente io svolto anche la
professione del giornalista del cronista
è stato un altro stratagemma eccellente
per accogliere delle storie in questo
caso the place era genova la mia città
natale e specialmente il centro storico
luogo dove vivevo e che allora soltanto
pochi incoscienti osavano frequentare
erano gli anni della prima ondata di
immigrazione dal nord africa un'ondata
di persone di cui gli autoctoni non
avevano per niente gradito l'arrivo
c'era un clima pesantissimo si respirava
un'aria di tensione costante che in
qualunque momento avrebbe potuto
deflagrare violentemente fu anche
un'estate piena di omicidi strani
un'estate caldissima in cui pareva che
la gente impazzisce uccidendo familiari
o perfetti sconosciuti come prendere
queste storie e farne qualcosa di
diverso
immaginando le ad esempio in una canzone
e questo fu il classico caso
in cui prendere delle storie cercare di
dare loro una forma di narrazione
differente in questo caso la forma
canzone ha modificato un'esistenza la
mia il premio tenco ascolta quella
canzone che si chiamava caldo da
impazzire e mi invitò come migliore
esordiente all'edizione del 1993 dandomi
ufficialmente la patente di cantautore
cioè questo avrei fatto nella vita e poi
quando arrivai a torino quasi 18 anni fa
il primo luogo in cui mi senti a casa
fu un porto e voi mi direte ma a torino
non c'è un porto e invece a torino il
porto c'è eccome
in questo caso the place e porta palazzo
un porto che non si affaccia sul mare ma
che dal mare porta e raccoglie come in
una gigantesca risacca donne uomini
bambini di ogni etnia e colore e lingua
ecco quello è davvero the place dove
nello stesso esatto momento puoi
trovarti a tangeri istanbul timisoara
lagos può incontrare la madonna di quito
in un bar di magrebini e giocare a carte
con la virgen de guadalupe nel retro
bottega di un artigiano rumeno torino mi
ha accolto una sera nei dintorni di
natale in questa gigantesca piazza dove
si stagliava una enorme altissima gru
illuminata cobalto era una delle prime
installazioni di luce d'artista e
ricordo che rimasi colpito da quella
scena al di là di ogni possibile
immaginario un brulicare di formiche
impazzite di ogni lingua ed etnia
sovrastate dall azzurro scuro di quella
gru che sembrava essere un viatico per
il cielo per il paradiso da raggiungere
o forse da cui scendere lì in quel
particolarissimo inferno ho scritto
anche una canzone dedicato a porta
palazzo ma per questa occasione ho
preferito sceglierne un'altra scritta da
da un caro collega un grandissimo
scrittore di canzoni che ho avuto la
fortuna di conoscere e anche ogni tanto
frequentare
e che purtroppo prematuramente scomparso
nella serie inaccettabile di lutti del
gianmaria testa
[Musica]
[Applauso]
al mercato di porta palazzo fanno la
fila fanno la fila le femmine da ragazzo
fanno la figlia hanno l'andazzo e si
lasciano indovina sotto le gonne sotto
le gonne e si lasciano indovinare sotto
le gomme le gomme vere
e sopra il molo del caricamento fanno la
coda fanno la coda gli uomini da bastone
fanno la coda sul cemento e si lasciano
perquisì sotto le giacche sotto le
giacche e si lasciano perquisire sotto
le giacche dargli cucine
ma una mattina di luna d'inverno c'è la
nave non c'era la neve sulla piazza
succede un inferno e tutti a chiedersi è
come dove dalla coda del caricamento
qualcuno grida qualcuno grida sulla
piazza di porta palazzo fra le ragazze
si rompeva fina
e ce n'è una sdraiata per terra sopra la
mele che sfavore ce n'è una sdraiata per
terra e tutte le altre fanno corona e
alle 7 45 era già nato era già fuori e
alle 7 45 hanno posato sul banco dei
fiori
mi favoriscano un documento di cera
guardi appena che arriva trafelata dal
caricamento per vedere che succedeva
favoriscano un documento è anche
qualcosa da dichiarare
questo è un caso di sgravi damento sul
suolo pubblico comunale
ma documenti non c'è nessuno e neanche
qualcuno dica niente solo la gente che
dire che spinge attorno ai garofani e
alle gardenie documenti non c'e nessuno
è quasi più niente da documentare solo
che un giorno di luna d'inverno tutta la
pianta voluto il suo fiore
ritorna la coda del caricamento torna la
fila torna l'andazzo degli uomini col
bastone delle femmine da ragazzo che si
lasciano perquisire sotto le già sotto 6
giacche che si lasciano indovinare sotto
le gonne le gomme ne che si lasciano
indovinare sotto le gonne con bene
i luoghi i luoghi le storie ti cambiano
la vita
se in questi luoghi immergerti se sai
respirarli se sei farti prendere per
mano e guidare senza opporre resistenza
evitando ogni tentazione di giudizio ma
cercando l'incanto la bellezza anche
dove incanto e bellezza
apparentemente non ci sono ma se cerchi
bene anche tra l'immondizia trovi l'uno
e l'altra mi ha cambiato la vita vedere
i monasteri di rila in bulgaria e poco
distante da lì i casermoni di cemento
nelle periferie di sofia che si ergono
nudi e solitari in distese di polvere e
nulla mi ha cambiato la vita
vedere la gioia l'allegria la sporcizia
e il degrado dei campi rom mi ha
cambiato la vita vivere nei vicoli di
genova fare colazione con i dirigenti
della banca carige con i transessuali di
pretoria mi ha cambiato la vita vedere
torino cambiare pelle
proprio nel periodo in cui sono venuto
ad abitarci vederla muoversi agilmente
in questo passaggio da città
potentemente industriale a metropoli
europea di cultura e di turismo mi ha
cambiato la vita avere la fortuna di
trovare la bellezza anche dove la
bellezza apparentemente non c'è ma ci
sono le storie e saper raccogliere e
raccontare una storia è molto più
importante di quanto crediamo è la forza
della storia della narrazione che rende
il contenuto coinvolgente appetibile
interessante tra le mie attività
collaterali allo scrivere canzoni andare
in giro per concerti c'è anche quella di
portare nelle scuole nei licei la grande
magnifica storia della canzone d'autore
e dovreste vedere davvero l'entusiasmo
l'attenzione la curiosità con cui questi
giovani giovanissimi studenti assorbono
queste informazioni perché sono storie
belle sono storie straordinarie sono
storie vere ma vanno raccontate bene
vanno raccontate con amore con passione
con libertà e partecipazione come
direbbe un altro gigante giorgio gaber e
allora godetevi le storie che sono
intorno a voi catturate le fate le
vostre condividete le con i vostri amici
i vostri alle vostre fidanzate mariti
mogli condividere con i vostri figli
mia figlia adesso a 14 anni quando ne
aveva sei o sette aveva già intuito che
la storia che nella storia di babbo
natale c'era qualcosa che non quadrava
così mi ha posto la domanda a bruciapelo
papa ma babbo natale esiste e le ho
risposto la verità esiste tutto quello a
cui ti piace credere e io alla forza
delle storie continuo a credere ma
ciecamente e spero possa essere così
anche per voi
grazie
[Applauso]